okay we are taking calls at 6 1 7 830
for 750 the next caller is now joining
me name town and I would love to hear
what's on your mind today hi my name is
Judy I'm from Texas and calling because
the epi pens are actual expensive yeah I
did find a website in Canada that gives
that sells them online for fifty dollars
instead of the 608 charge here hmm so
this is kind of a public service thing
for people that need these epic Anson
can afford it yeah I know uh over the
weekend I'm sorry I was gonna mention
over the weekend I was at a wedding in
Pennsylvania and my girlfriend was stung
by a bee for the first time and although
we were sort of uh joking someone said I
hope you don't need an EpiPen because of
what's going on with the the price
gouging on on epi pens you know I I
don't obviously i'm not giving medical
advice here there are many you know
officially officially the the line is um
don't buy anything from another country
because the FDA can't guarantee its
safety but the reality is that many of
the things in other countries are
actually regulated more strictly by that
country's equivalent of the FDA so what
I would say to people is do your
research if you're looking at getting
something from Canada right exactly and
it's a legitimate website i went to the
website and you know i would trust
canada for especially for something like
this no I also found out that the cost
to make these things not the packaging
but the cost of the drug itself yeah 61
cents so even at nifty dollars that is
quite a nice little profit there isn't
it where it is but I'd rather give it to
Canada than six hundred dollars to
somebody else it's a millionaire already
yeah no III understand exactly thank you
so much for the call and glad for for
making the audience of we're aware of
that uh one could we've had so far two
women phone callers which ties the total
of
phone callers we've had and both from
the south warby parker is offering a
free five day home try-on to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses i personally wear warby parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try-on and support the david pakman show
at warby parker trial dot-com / tdps i
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home try-on I was
able to pick five pairs that i liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker
dot-com / TDPS it costs nothing